The later that a software development problem is detected,
the more expensive it is to fix it.
Hence, we want to find problems as early as possible in the process.
Reviews are a cost effective way to find problems in all kinds of artifacts,
including design documents.
Going further, we want to detect deep problems if we can.
And reviews run the risk of revealing shallow problems with a document self or
with superficial aspects of the design.
To reveal deep problems requires exposure of the design to
experienced designers who are among the most highly paid and
time stressed people in the development process.
Therefore it makes sense to have the design review be as focused and
well-run as possible.
To do this reviews should be institutionalized.
By that I mean, they should be a formally defined process element and
part of the corporate culture.
By doing so, the short-term costs involved in conducting reviews will be
more than offset by the eventual saving on reduced maintenance and
increased customer satisfaction.